l'engin de 80 tonnes toutes roues en
l'air avec sa longue flèche sur le toit
d'une école primaire non loin de la
mairie des trois îles et selon les
témoignages c'est arrivé en douceur sans
faire de victimes fortes heureusement en
fait le sol s'est affaissé sous le poids
de l'engin pendant ces vacances de
toussaint était convenu de pouvoir
remplacer quelques tôles afin de
d'éviter les infiltrations à l'école et
voilà se passer maintenant
même s'il va se passer bien sûr l'engin
soit enlevé bon il faut un technicien
qui semble-t-il doit arriver d'allemagne
et qui va faire rentrer la flèche des
six
le dio mardi et après nous allons
réparer ces dégâts
un accident impressionnant une grue
mobile de plus de 300000 euros pas de
fuite de gasoil ni d'huile constaté le
site a bien sûr été sécurisés qu'est ce
que vous allez faire me rendre au bureau
j'appelle les experts voilà c'est tout
c'est la première fois que vous vivez
une situation pas tout à fait c'est pour
ça il ya le groupe électrogène qui
secoue à l'école qu'il faudra remplacer
bon c'est souvent entre 20 et 30 mille
euros et peut-être dix mille euros de
travaux d'équipement les muons bien
tenues simplement le faux plafond ou
l'autre et en braille tomber l'école
n'est pas enfoncé n'est pas défoncer
n'est pas écrasé il ya une salle de
classe qui est touchée selon le maire
tout rentrera dans l'ordre avant la
rentrée le 5 novembre prochain